I want to show you one more clip of the
new Disney Plus show Proud family which
is on right now I don't have Disney plus
I canceled it you have Disney plus no
Disney plus no Disney Plus in this room
okay uh but this is proud family on
Disney plus enjoy
how do you understand love don't you no
no I do not understand anything about
my virginity what's that supposed to
mean you know what it means you're doing
it right now doing what being defensive
about race Robert D'Angelo wrote a whole
book about it read it yet again
same um
covering everything
[Music]
he said his people would never own
slaves
they just dismissed me like that white
fertility okay so you must understand
this is not entertainment for children
this is pure propagandic
um disinformation intentional confusion
of children why would any child let's
say a six-year-old a seven-year-old
eight-year-old is watching that how
about entertaining them for the sake of
entertainment
maybe you could teach them something but
to teach them the ideas of white
fragility which is basically the the
Genesis the beginning of all of what is
so wrong with this woke mind disease and
that parents don't even think about it
they just plop that kid down in front of
that TV and by the way I get the
inclination for this with a six month
old and a four-month-old one of the few
things when they're both kind of going
nuts at the same time and they're really
well behaved but I've had a couple
moments where I've sat them in front of
the TV with me we put on we put on
nature shows right we just watch frogs
jumping around in some fish and a lion
and an elephant they seem to be big on
elephants but I get the inclination to
just put your kid down in front of the
TV and then you think oh Disney I have
some recollection of Disney being decent
they're not gonna really try to
brainwash my child are they no it's
Disney of old
[Music]
thank you